Hugo Weaving isn't one to be pushed
around even by mighty Marvel the actor
recently revealed that he passed on the
opportunity to reprise her role of red
skull in Avengers infinity war and
Avengers endgame and contract
negotiations with Marvel Studios hit a
serious snag we even spoke about the
situation during an interview with Time
Out's to promote his appearance and the
visit a staged production being mounted
at London's famed National Theatre the
skulls reappearance as keeper of the
soul stone on the planet Vermeer was one
of the more unexpected and
crowd-pleasing moments in infinity war
but Sir this day there are probably a
number of fans who don't realize that it
wasn't weaving under the makeup rather
it was Russ Marquand of The Walking Dead
Fame who's so thoroughly nailed weavings
take on the character that audiences
could be forgiven for failing to spot
the substitution surprisingly weaving
indicated two timeouts that in contrast
to remarks he made in 2012 indicating
that plain the skull was quote not
something he would want to do again he
actually enjoyed the chance to indulge
his villainous impulses on the roll and
would have been down to return if I only
Marvel had played ball the actor
explained I loved playing that character
red skull it was a lot of fun we were
all obliged to sign up for three
pictures I was thinking red skull
probably wouldn't come back in another
Captain America movie but he may welcome
back as a villain in an Avengers film
this turns out to be reasonably accurate
although the skull was more of a
supporting character than a villain in
Infinity Warren ends game so what went
wrong
weaving says that what he was indeed
approached to reprise the role Marvel
basically failed to abide by the terms
of the agreement that was forged when he
signed on for Captain America the First
Avenger Weaving claimed that pushed back
on the contract so we agreed on and so
the money they offered me to return was
much less than I got for the very first
one and this was for two films and the
promise when we first signed the
contracts was that the money would grow
each time I actually found the go
shading with them through my agent
impossible and I didn't really want to
do it that much but I would have done it
he resented my genius and
to deny me what was rightfully mine well
that's certainly a bummer to know but
like we said Marquand stepped in and
absolutely crushed a role in both movies
in fact even though it's tough to
envision a circumstance in which the
Hydra mastermind turned infinity stone
Guardian would make a return to the MCU
Marquand has enthusiastically stated
that he would love to come back for
another go-round as a skull we have the
feeling you're now asking a couple of
questions
wait a minute looper you're asking are
they making another Matrix movie where
we see weaving in a signature role of
Agent Smith one more time yes they are
and no no he won't
hey you've got questions and we've got
answers even if they're not exactly the
ones you want later in his timeout
interview Weaving explained that he had
indeed been offered the role of Smith
and director lana wachowski is upcoming
as yet entitled matrix 4 but
unfortunately the stars had stubbornly
refused to align weaving ditched matrix
4 is a very different story it's
unfortunate but actually I had this
offer for the visit and then the offer
came for the matrix so I knew it was
happening but I didn't have days I
thought I could do both and it took 8
weeks to work out that the dates would
work I held off on accepting his role in
the visit for that period I was in touch
with lana wachowski but in the end she
decided that the dates weren't going to
work so we'd sorted the dates and then
she sort of changed her mind they're
pushing on ahead without me
that is also a bummer I said either
means a matrix for will be without Agent
Smith altogether all will have to fill
the role with someone other than weaving
who's I see Nia mechanical delivery help
to find the character we can't help but
wonder if what Chelsea has given
Marquand a call he does a pretty solid
Hugo Weaving impression check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos but your favorite
stuff are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and to the bail so you
don't miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]